[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
uh Travis Kelsey joining us two-time
Super Bowl champ Kelsey Jam Travis's
first ever music and Food Fest taking
place in Kansas City draft night and uh
he's also hooking up with Lowe's to
support the NFL draft stage build
introducing Lowe's new MVPs uh business
tools and you can learn more at Lowe's
on Tick Tock Travis Kelsey joining us on
the program good to see you again take
me back to the draft what were you told
leading up to the draft and and where
did you think that you were going to end
up going
yeah I mean obviously everyone has the
hopes of uh of being you know maybe a
first round pick I was dreaming big
um most of the talk was I was going to
be somewhere in the late second uh mid
third round
um and uh I guess there were really two
teams that my agent was talking to that
had
real interest in me
um one of them being the Jets uh and
that's really the only story that I
remember hearing from my agent that was
like it could be possible
um but when they went Geno Smith it was
just kind of like a
I don't know it was uh I just got thrown
in the blender like just getting picked
up by hopefully somebody taking a chance
on me just because my athleticism you
know something like that but uh yeah I
ended up going uh early in the third and
um
man I didn't know anything about Kansas
City I remember not knowing a single
thing about the Chiefs um obviously Tony
Gonzalez was uh was a legend of the
sport at the time but it was now did you
know if it was Kansas City Missouri or
Kansas City Kansas
see I didn't know I didn't know yeah I
thought it was Kansas for sure I thought
Kansas City was 1000 in Kansas and I
made the huge mistake of that uh but it
was um because I actually got the phone
call from uh Missouri number so I
thought I was going to St Louis
so I thought I saw the Missouri number
coming in and I was just like oh man
this is crazy I'm going to St Louis like
I don't know anything about St Louis
either and sure enough it was Andy Reid
that called me so I knew instantly that
it was the Chiefs but I wonder though if
you had gone higher like you know Brady
used it as a chip on his shoulder that
he went so late and trell Dave and you
know a lot of these guys are like hey
I'm going after all these guys you took
in front of me if you'd gone in the
first round would you be any different
in your career
um
I really I don't even think of it like
that anymore I feel like I think of it
more so as uh the more I was in the
building
The more I've been in Kansas City under
coach Reed I just been so fortunate that
I landed here I'm just so happy I didn't
go earlier on in in the draft and that I
was able to just be under a great coach
to have this opportunity to keep growing
and and growing within the position and
within the offense and things like that
I didn't even really I mean maybe the
Eagles the Eagles were like kind of the
only one because my brother was there
they took a tight end a few picks ahead
of me so I thought maybe you know I had
a little grudge against that because
they had opportunity of making you know
give me a chance to play with my brother
in the NFL but other than that man I was
just so fortunate that I was in Kansas
City because of the situation we had but
don't you think your brother would have
had some Sway With The Eagles they come
to you and say hey we're thinking about
drafting your did they even go to your
brother and say we're thinking about
drafting your brother
um not to my knowledge not to my
knowledge no but um they got they got a
damn good one in Zachary yeah he was
pretty good worked out for both both
organizations yeah did you know who
Mahomes was when they drafted him
no I remember watching him at Tech a
little bit I'm seeing the highlights and
stuff like that but um I really didn't
know much about him other than other
than he was a gunslinger okay but you
had to be then just like us because I
watched him but I had no idea that he
was going to be he was every day
every day was just a mind-blowing you
know experience seeing this guy just how
comfortable he was as a rookie to to be
able to try these things in practice
um you know especially under a guy like
coach Andy Reed is very you know very
disciplined oriented you know you gotta
you got to do things the right way you
know this this thing is well mapped out
this offense is well thought out well
mapped out and
um for him to play as free he's as he
does instead in such a like strategic
offense
um man it just blew my mind every single
day how he how he was just making plays
and creating Paulie would you give me
the draft profile
hi Travis yeah the good or the bad give
me the bad because you know he wants to
hear the good he was a really good
athlete and you know well according to
nfl.com okay doesn't have blazing speed
not a tremendously explosive athlete
doesn't come out of his brakes that well
sometimes plays a little recklessly
those are the negatives okay you want to
uh you want to counter
um
man uh that's I guess it's kind of spot
on was I was like all I heard was I
didn't have blazing speed I don't know
why that just jumped out at me it was
the first one I guess
um I mean I've taken a I've taken a
screen 81 to the house I don't know if
that's blazing speed but that's fast
enough if you ask me dad I don't know I
never I when I watch your games I'm like
how the bleep is he always open
I I know I mean explain to me how are
you always open uh there's so many
freaking variables um one one thing you
gotta always keep in your uh your Hip
Pocket when you're thinking about that
or in the back of your mind is um I got
coach Andy redialing these things up for
me so he's already putting the defense
to a a certain challenge he's presenting
a challenge to them that's uh that's not
easy you got to know kind of number
counts and and where guys are at at all
times and all the possibilities of each
route so it's just uh almost
manipulating everybody and just trying
to make everyone feel real confused or
just a tad bit late on their reads as a
defensive I feel like if I'm always
putting the defense in a reactionary
position uh I got the upper hand
we're talking to uh Travis Kelsey if I
had you run against Tyreek Hill and you
ran a hundred don't do that to me okay
but how how much would he beat you by in
a hundred yard dash
man
I would hope it wouldn't get further
than like 20 yards well he he's not
going to beat you by 20 yards is he man
I've seen that guy take off before Dan
and I did not think I had any chance of
getting closer to him
like with him him with the ball in his
hands for sure he's a he's a whole
different speed with the ball in his
hands and I tried to get that match with
Usain Bolt because I thought and they
both agreed to it and I thought if you
did 60 yards
I really believe Tyreek Hill could get
Usain Bolt it's the next 40 that you're
in trouble because
what do you think no I'm um I'm taking
Tyrique I mean 60 I'm taking Tyree I'm
not gonna lie though Tyrique is one of
those guys because he uh he admitted to
me uh when he was with the chief said
he's more of a 200 meter guy like he
thinks that he really just keeps it
going as he hits the turn uh to the
straightaway so I um I don't know I
don't know but he is he's a
he gets shot out of a cannon uh those
first 50 and 60 are not slow by any
means what's the draft party you're
hosting
the Kelsey Jam baby we're bringing a
music of Food Fest to uh to Kansas City
man we thought it was the perfect time
uh after a Super Bowl I've always wanted
to throw a party for Kansas City man and
just have everybody come out outside of
a parade uh and after Super Bowl but I
think that it was uh the draft coming
into the city
um and it was just an awesome
opportunity to kind of bring some people
together for a fun opportunity man how
long did it take you to sober up after
the Super Bowl Parade
oh man I'll tell you what
that's a that's a shock too by the way
that's not a problem um I didn't know
what that was you thought you said yeah
I hadn't had to clear that up no I am
I'm sobered up now we're uh we're
getting fired up and ready to to go get
another one man so it was it was a fun
two months but this will be the last
hoor out this weekend for me we got to
get back to it did you uh keep the
football from the Super Bowl touchdown
I do I have it in I have it in my locker
yeah okay because I was wondering about
that in the moment do you even think
about that
no no I remember the uh the first one I
ever scored in the Super Bowl was the
one on my first Super Bowl in Miami
against the 49ers and uh we were still
on the comeback we were down 10. we're
still I think even more than that we
were still on the comeback and I just
threw the ball in the ground I just ran
back to the sideline as fast as possible
and uh later on
thought I you know I might want to keep
that I could uh that could bring back
some good memories have you watched the
Super Bowl back as a team
no not yet not yet we haven't uh I don't
even want to stay yet I uh we we
definitely I mean we didn't do the last
one or the one before that I know
everyone kind of peeks at it uh by their
by themselves and talks about certain
plays and things like that but I went
out a viewing party and then have
another Victory Parade after the viewing
party
I'll be the cruise director but I I
think it'd be just another way let
Kansas City know we're thinking of you
let's have a viewing party get uh you
know 75 100 000 of your closest friends
watch some TV we might add we might add
this thing to Kelsey jam oh I like it'll
make it a full experience I like that
and then you're working with Lowe's as
well aren't you oh yeah the low I'm uh
working with Lowe's again this year part
of the Lowe's home team and um
helping out uh I guess Kansas City draft
comes there the draft comes to Kansas
City
um Lowe's home team and the lowest Pros
that are under lows uh they're making
the draft stage as memorable as possible
for these uh these draftees and and
everyone involved and I can't thank them
enough for doing this for the city it's
a it's a beautiful experience to even be
a part of the other day we pulled up on
the stage and uh and helped hand out
some new tools and some new uh some new
gear and everything so that these guys
could feel comfortable and get the job
done in time and it's uh it's been fun
to be a part of Lowe's this year and
don't rest on your laurels here okay I
mean Gronk still is ahead of you a
little bit isn't he
oh 100 I think uh what do you need to do
to surpass Gronk as in your mind their
past oh man I just want to get as many
Super Bowls as he does okay if I if I do
that I've uh I've at least in my mind
leveled the playing field and for
somebody I think does championships mean
everything somebody who doesn't have
great speed and doesn't come out of
breaks very well
I'll be working on that this summer okay
you'll be working on that this summer uh
hey great to talk to you have fun at the
draft party and uh congrats again
always fun baby everybody will see you
at Kelsey Jam Kelsey Jim Travis's first
ever music and Food Fest taking place in
Kansas City around the draft